today on the Matt wall show the left and
the media are enraged today because of
my allegedly racist mermaid opinions now
this is a very very important issue to
them will I finally fall to my knees and
apologize you'll have to stay tuned to
find out also two videos went viral this
week of brutal assaults in public
schools why does this seem to be an
increasing Trend and Chris Ruffo has
more information about that alleged bomb
threat at Boston Children's Hospital
something isn't quite adding up there
and Jill Biden says that children should
have access to all books all books in
their school libraries in our daily
cancellation we must finally cancel
Starbucks Baristas it's been a long time
coming it's now time all of that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
Ro versus Wade has been overturned and
this battle is now finally leaving DC
and going to the Grassroots no group in
America is better positioned than 40
Days for life with about a million
Volunteers in a thousand cities 40 Days
for life holds peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities they have a larger
presence exactly where they're needed in
blue states with California being their
largest state some former abortion
facility directors say that these vigils
can cause the abortion no show rate to
go as high as 75 percent which is very
damaging to their abortion business
which is very good
for the children who are being saved by
that these law-abiding vigils have
closed many abortion businesses in
America and nearly half of those closed
abortion facilities were in Liberal
cities where abortion will remain legal
including closures in San Francisco
Chicago and Seattle so they're exactly
where they need to be fighting this out
40 Days for life is effectively changing
hearts and Minds in the Grassroots to
end abortion you can learn more about
them by checking out their locations
podcasts and free magazine at 40
daysforlife.com remember this is the
time to be fighting to be in the fight
if the fight is not over so if you want
more information go to 40 Days for
life.com
you know there are times when I provoke
the ire of the left and wind up trending
on social media and generating negative
headlines because I've said something
that they find offensive about an
important cultural topic and then there
are times when I provoke the ire of the
left and wind up trending on social
media and generating negative headlines
because I advocated for a scientifically
accurate mermaid with translucent skin
now this latest outrage falls into that
second and admittedly very specific
category so those who listened to show
yesterday may recall the very brief
moment during the comment section
segment of the show and I responded to
someone who was giving their opinion on
the black Little Mermaid issue in my
response I asserted that scientifically
it makes no sense for Ariel to have dark
skin in fact I suggested that she ought
to be translucent and skeletal and
horrifying like a real deep sea fish
our loyal fans over at Media Matters
heard those remarks as they hear
literally everything else I say because
they're obsessed with me and want to
date me and they immediately posted it
to Twitter and published an article on
their site with the headline daily wire
host says it is unscientific to cast a
black person as a mermaid other
left-wing blogs picked it up like the
site Alternet which reports and I'll
read a little bit of that report because
I think it fairly captures what actually
happened uh quote
right-wing daily wire podcaster Matt
Walsh threw a fit on Wednesday over the
new live-action remake of the classic
Disney film The Little Mermaid because
the main character Ariel is portrayed by
actress Hallie Bailey who was Black Matt
said that while he is sympathetic to the
more racial inclusion and fictional
Works he opposes Bailey's casting
because of marine biology quoting me now
quote also by the way with the little
mermaid can we also just mentioned that
from a scientific perspective it doesn't
make a lot of sense to have someone with
darker skin who lives deep in the ocean
Walsh complained I mean if anything not
only should Little Mermaid be pale she
should actually be translucent he
continued if you look at deep sea
creatures they're like translucent they
have no pigmentation whatsoever and
they're just these horrifying they look
like skeletons floating around in the
ocean that's what the little mermaid
mermaid should look like she should be
totally pale and skeletal where you can
see her skull through her face Walsh
noted adding that this would be a
version of The Little Mermaid that I
would watch
now that is indeed an accurate and full
quote which I do appreciate Media
Matters on Twitter provided the full
video but they were more selective in
their caption so Jason came Campbell
tweeted the video but the caption was
just daily wire host says it's
unscientific to cast a black person as a
mermaid
now
uh which again is what I said but then
didn't go further with the uh with with
the rest of it
from there it was sort of Off to the
Races my statements calling for a
translucent mermaid were picked up by
other media Outlets like Newsweek they
had a headline about it it even went all
the way across the world the Sydney
Morning Herald in Australia was
reporting on reporter started emailing
me asking for comment on the issue which
I was more than happy to provide by the
way leftists across the nation expressed
their outrage I was one of the top
trending topics on Twitter all night and
still today because of this my allegedly
racist translucent supremacist views
ignited a national Firestorm now just
reading through a few of these angry
tweets just for fun
um one says wait wait wait first these
fools want to say that science doesn't
matter when it comes to vaccines and the
like but then want to be science
Guardians about fictional creatures Josh
Marshall at the talking points memo
tweeted I shouldn't laugh because the
racism isn't funny but they struggle to
present their racism as scientific have
you ever even met a fish
he actually wrote that have you met any
fish they don't look like people with a
few exceptions they're not white what an
effing clown another tweet says quite
possibly the strangest thing about
self-described Theocratic fascist Matt
Walsh's argument for why scientifically
a mermaid couldn't be black is the fact
that it's just wrong he's confusing
panning changing someone's skin tone to
the amount of melanin in someone's skin
another one says attention Matt Walsh F
your scientific perspective mermaids
aren't real just say you're a racist and
take up significantly less air time bye
and there's this there are a lot of
extraordinarily dumb and pathetic
racists in the world but Matt Walsh puts
them all to shame with pearl clutching
cakes like this another from a woman
named Victoria brownworth who builds
herself
as an award-winning journalist says
quote wait Matt Walsh says there's
science behind his racist Take On The
Little Mermaid casting is someone gonna
break it to him that mermaids are
mythical creatures and Disney makes
animated features for kids
now there are many thousands more where
those came from Ted Liu got in on the
dog pile so did CNN correspondent John
Harwood many others conservative
masochist and [ __ ] David French joined
in
um the outrage reached into unexpected
Corners the media liaison for the
Portland Police Department
for some reason
sent me hate mail about this calling me
garbage for my comments about a
translucent mermaid this guy's name by
the way is David singer and will put his
message up on the screen incidentally in
the message that I'm putting up on the
screen you can see his email address
there which is a shame I wish we could
block that out or something but I forgot
to and now it's out there and you can
all see it please don't email him though
I'm not asking you to do that anyway he
was hired by the Portland Maine Police
Department during the defund the police
hysteria as one of the three civilian
Liaisons and his job which he has paid a
salary by the taxpayers for is to
facilitate community and media relations
and this is his media outreach strategy
evidently a very interesting approach to
say the least he actually sent me that
bit of hate mail called me garbage and
then blocked me so that I couldn't
respond this is media outreach okay this
is what the Portland Police Department
in Maine needs all told
the left was very upset about my push
for a greater translucent representation
in mermaid casting and let me just say
to begin with
but I am glad the left has chosen to
take my comments seriously
I was of course being totally serious
when I made them I am not one to joke
I would never engage in something as
juvenile as sarcasm when I say something
as my audience knows it means that I am
100 sincere all the time and I
especially would never joke about an
issue as serious as translucent
representation in Hollywood
so the three points I want to make here
first of all I have long been an
advocate for the translucent population
a fighter for Trans rights you might say
translucent individuals have been
marginalized for far too long and now
even film roles that rightfully belong
to them have been appropriated I ask you
when was the last time you saw a
skeletal translucent goblin-like
monstrosity cast in any movie
now granted we have one as a speaker of
the house right now but that is hardly
enough
if they will not earn roles in films
about deep sea creatures who sing
then what hope do they have
translucent people exist and they
deserve to be affirmed translucent
rights are human rights translucent
lives matter
second
many on the left have sent me messages
or left comments insisting that my
mermaid racial theories are factually
incorrect they have presented many
arguments seeking to debunk my thesis a
journalist named there are a lot of
journalists by the way who are chiming
in on this and there's a journalist
named Catherine Marshall she sent a
whole string of tweets fact checking my
alleged misinformation and insisting
that mermaids are more like seals who
breathe air at the surface that's what
she said and as she reminded me
indignantly
seals are black
but this argument fails because mermaids
live on the ocean floor and as you may
recall in the original film Ariel's
trips to the surface are a source of
great controversy in the mermaid
Community they don't want her to go
there at all this means that mermaids do
not need to surface in order to breathe
air as seals do no living on the ocean
floor with flounders and evil octopuses
clearly qualifies her as a deep sea
creature she certainly lives deep enough
where there wouldn't be nearly enough
light penetration to necessitate high
concentrations of melanin in the skin
indeed the lack of light penetration
would create as I argued a translucent
appearance this would be both
evolutionary an evolutionary adaptation
allowing for greater camouflage from
predators and a logical result of the
lack of sunlight so do your mermaid
research before you try to engage with
me on this subject you need to bring
mermaid facts and mermaid logic to this
conversation
by the way
I demand this level of accuracy out of
every Disney film it's one of the
reasons I've always objected to Beauty
and the Beast for one thing the story
promotes bestiality as Beauty begins to
fall in love with what is essentially a
large talking Buffalo
for another the servants who turned into
household objects and pieces of
furniture would in reality be so
psychologically devastated by this
transformation they'd be in no mood to
perform song and dance numbers for the
Beast female prisoners
not to mention they wouldn't have vocal
cords or a musculoskeletal system that
could facilitate that sort of physical
movement
third and final point
I am
the Beloved and revered LGBT author of
Johnny the walrus
I literally wrote a book about marine
animals Johnny The Walrus is not just a
masterpiece of children's literature but
also the seminal scientific Treatise on
the subject of aquatic mammals
so those who are questioning my
statements
are therefore not only engaging in
homophobia and gay Erasure but also are
refusing to listen to and Trust the
experts
this is dangerous and toxic Behavior not
to mention an example of stochastic
terrorism
as an expert in the field
and as an advocate
the translucent community
I will not allow myself to be silenced
or marginalized
now let's get to our five headlines
okay by the way I should also mention
that the outlet
hit C news hitc news which seems to be a
British entertainment news site they
have a report on the mermaid issue and
they do include the whole statement I
provided to them when they reached out
for a statement so what they report is
uh Matt Walsh told hit C news I have
long been an advocate for the rights of
translucent people I believe it's time
we start giving these casting
opportunities to this marginalized
Community translucent rights or human
rights so they did include my whole
statement in their report which I really
appreciate I don't know if the other
media Outlets will do that Newsweek
reported on it didn't even ask for me
ask her a statement for me to begin with
although even in their case I'm glad
that they are focusing on this extremely
important issue now
we move on a couple of uh videos have
gone viral this week both showing brutal
beatings that happened in public schools
um
and in both cases the assailants were
black victims were white now I'm not
even sure
how much of these videos we can actually
show
um but we'll show one and then the other
and and uh I don't know if YouTube takes
us down because it's so violent but you
have to actually see you hear about a a
beating in a public school something
like that you think you think like a
maybe the kind of fist fights that you
witnessed or maybe were a part of when
you were in school but this goes beyond
that so first we'll uh we'll watch this
one you can see it's a group of kids and
then what the the victim gets slammed
against the Wall's head is against the
wall now and I've looked for an update
on the story and I haven't seen it
because you can see
he's grabbing his throat which is
a very concerning thing
and then while he's on the ground he
gets kicked in the face
which by the way could kill somebody
then we have the other incident also in
a bathroom
and in this case it's the same deal
there are people standing around
watching and filming
and it's the same situation where the
victim is on the ground and still
getting pummeled
kicked
and all the rest of it that's brutal not
quite as brutal as the first video but
still really bad
now
one thing you'll always see in these
kinds of videos you you always see that
right the the kick in the head when the
victim is down at every every time you
can it's just guaranteed
victim is on the ground defenseless has
given up the fight and in many cases was
never fighting in the first place didn't
want to be a part of any fight and
they're on the ground and then they just
get kicked in the head every single time
it's barbaric animalistic Savage
Behavior no honest just no honor at all
right no recognition of the other
person's
Humanity
which again it separates it from maybe
some of the fights that you saw when you
were in school or took part in where you
get into a fight with someone and you're
trying to win you're not actually trying
to kill them though it's like you're not
trying to to uh paralyze them or put
them in a hospital for a month
most the time the kind of fights that
you think about it's just sort of it's
it's a it's a lot of uh bravado and that
sort of thing it's kind of masculine
energy that's uh that that boys have and
a lot of times they
you know the two kids will start getting
each other's face and they don't even
want to fight that's why they that's why
they get into each other's face in
school because they know it's going to
get broken up
um and so there's that there's kind of
that category of fight which is one
thing and it's bad you shouldn't do it
in school and kids do it should be
punished
but again that's not this this is
someone who's outnumbered
and just being totally brutalized often
for no real reason
um now 12 news in Beaumont Texas has
more on one of these incidents I think
it's the second video we saw uh a a
Beaumont city councilman is calling for
state and National level change after
what he describes as a horrific incident
at Westbrook High School
uh Beaumont city councilman Mike Getz
said in a Facebook post a student was
brutally beaten in one of the boys
restrooms while other students watched
councilman Mike Getz said he was asked
to be a Beaumont ISD Ambassador the
morning after
the first night of the Ambassador
training get gets saw a video that has
since surfaced on social media uh he
said my cell phone was blowing up with
people sending me links to a horrific
incident at Westbrook the video which 12
News has seen appears to have been taken
in the boys bathroom a teenage boy can
be seen punching another boy who's on
the floor in the face and had at least
14 times before kicking him in the face
the boy on the floor tries to cover his
face as he's hit multiple times other
teams can be seen in the bathroom when
the incident is taking place
um now here's some important details
about this
the boy who was seen punching and
kicking the other
uh boy was arrested and could possibly
face robbery and assault charges the
councilman hopes he'll be prosecuted as
an adult but get said quote this is not
his first rodeo he has been arrested
before but current and State current
state of federal law allowed these
offenders back on campus after a
relatively short stay at a Juvenile
Detention Facility
so that's what's happening in the school
system right now if you're wondering why
you see these kinds of videos with
increasing regularity it's because the
kids who do this end up back in the
school system a lot of times they're not
charged at all I mean the fact that
we're even talking about this
hypothetically oh he could be charged
with assault could be what do you mean
could be
if that's not criminal felony assault I
don't know what is if that doesn't
qualify then what do you have to do if
punching and wailing on someone kicking
them in the head when they're on the
ground doesn't count as felony assault
criminal assault that sends you to jail
then what does
and yeah this kid has done this before
and um
ends up back in school doing it again
now a few things here
first of all we we all know obviously
that if you flip things around
and it's a group of white kids beating a
black kid it makes national news we know
that it's not just national news it's a
national crisis
is a national crisis it is uh there's
press conferences at the White House
about it there's marches there's rallies
there's riots there's just it's the only
thing you hear about in for a month at
least
if you flip it around
um
but the problem with focusing on the
hypocrisy now I think that the hypocrisy
should be mentioned the double standard
should be mentioned
we talked about a few days ago on the
show
there's an attitude among some
conservatives that I didn't want to tell
you the racial double standard let's not
even talk about that it's lame to talk
about well so we're just going to accept
it
I'm not saying that talking about it
will solve the problem in and of itself
but I don't accept it so I'm going to
point it out every single time
the problem though with focusing just on
the hypocrisy
is that it lets us off the hook from
actually dealing with the reality with
the uncomfortable reality which is that
in these videos
you know we say that well if this the
races were reversed it'd be national
news
okay what's the unspoken part of that
because most of the time you stop there
you don't keep talking
but the next sentence is
um
we never see videos in the reverse
they almost don't exist and maybe there
are a few examples but we can assume
that there probably aren't at least not
recently because we would know about
them
so that is the uncomfortable kind of
unspoken reality is that
um in these kinds of videos It's almost
always a group of black kids mercilessly
brutalizing a white kid that's just a
fact
almost never the reverse Almost Never
it almost always goes this way the way
you see in the video
again it's a fact might be uncomfortable
but it's true
so what do we do with that how do we
make sense of it
we can make sense of it in a few
different ways I mean one thing we could
point to is the breakdown of the family
unit which has something to do with it
and the breakdown of the family unit is
is happening across the country in every
community and in every racial
demographic but it is as I think
everyone knows worse in the black
community than it is anywhere else
there you're dealing with 70 sometimes
80 depending on the communities
sometimes even more than 80 uh
fatherless home rate and and uh yeah
when you see this kind of behavior from
a kid
again not just fighting but like this
kind of brutal Savage Behavior
and in one case it's go you're going
after someone smaller than you there's
no interest in a fight trying to kill
them
because this is not just assault this is
attempted murder you kick someone in the
head when they're on the ground you were
trying to kill them that's attempted
murder
you see someone behaving that way you
can guarantee
and you're going to be right 99.9 of the
time that there's no father in the home
this is someone who does not have a
strong masculine role model in the home
and we know that because they've never
had masculinity demonstrated to them
so they're acting out in this way
because no one has ever shown them how a
man is supposed to act and how a man is
supposed to harness his kind of
masculine energy and aggression
which is one of the crucial services
that a father provides to his family is
to show the boys in that family what
they're supposed to do with all of this
energy that they have as a as a male
um
so we know that and there's also just
been no firm hand in the home
someone who can draw a line and say to
the kid you're not going to behave this
way
I mean everyone knows it's a it's a
stereotype but it's all it's not a
stereotype it's also true that uh
in most families where there is a mother
and a father present the kids tend to be
better behaved around their dad
and uh you know if Dad's at work and
they're not behaving well Mom can use as
a threat well I were to tell your father
about this when when he gets home and
that's a threat that resonates with kids
in the reverse you rarely hear about the
reverse
okay like my wife will use that threat
with my kids we're gonna tell Daddy
about this when he gets home that
resonates with them they know they don't
want they don't want that
but when I'm watching the kids by myself
um I I'm not gonna do that I'm not gonna
say we're gonna tell Mom about this when
she gets home
and it's not because they don't respect
their mother or anything like that it's
just because their mother's their mother
it's different for the father
so you could you could tell that this is
uh these are kids who don't have that
influence in the home
that's part of it part of what explains
the racial Dynamics here here's the
other part
um
perhaps
when you demonize a group of people
as our society has done with white
people and especially with white men
white boys white males you know when you
demonize them
when you paint them as the villains
and you you drill this into people's
head you're giving license
to others to treat them this way
so I don't know maybe there's a maybe
there's a correlation here
maybe there's correlation that also
indicates causation in this case maybe
when you you take a group of people and
you demonize them you demonize them you
demonize them and then you see this
uptick in that very same group of people
being treated in horrible and brutal and
horrific ways yeah you know maybe we can
start drawing some
lines here connecting these dots
just a thought
by the way talking about this on Twitter
a couple days ago and I got a message
from a few message messages from
teachers talking about you know exactly
this problem the violence in schools
so this is a message from teacher says
Mr Walsh I quit teaching high school
because a small section of the student
population was terrorizing the whole
campus that video of the smaller kid
getting beaten down the bathroom is a
common occurrence as a black man I
pleaded with my principal to kick those
delinquents out of school instead people
who complain get harassed I'm from a
different state than where this occurred
this is a national problem often the
media teachers get the focus but no one
is asking this did the principal who
knew they had violent students on their
campus get fired most of those
administrators know about the violent
students
this is um
well we're just we're driving the good
teachers out of the out of the business
entirely driving them out because what
are they supposed to do about this
and when you have kids on the campus who
are empowered to just do whatever they
want have no respect for authority
whatsoever what are you supposed to do
with that
all right this is from New York Times it
says the Supreme Court said on Wednesday
that uh it would let stand for now a
ruling that Yeshiva University must
recognize an LGBT student group the vote
was five to four with the majority
saying that the University of modern
Orthodox Jewish institution in Manhattan
must first pursue challenges to the
ruling and State Court Justice Samuel
Alito writing for the Florida Center
said that further challenges were
pointless that the majority had
inflicted grave harm on the University's
right to Religious Freedom
uh he wrote quote a state's imposition
on its of its own mandatory
interpretation of scripture is a
shocking development that calls out for
review
the majority's order was brief unsigned
and provisional which is typical when
the justices Rule and applications
seeking emergency relief it criticized
the University's litigation strategy
saying its lawyers had not asked a state
appeals court to speed its appeal and
had not properly sought to block the
trial judge's ruling in the meantime
the order said quote if applicants seek
and receive neither expedited review nor
internally from the New York courts they
may return to this court and so they are
basically they're kind of punting it
down the line a bit but
um this is really an easy case
this is an easy case to adjudicate it's
an easy case to to analyze from a
constitutional perspective and a
religious freedom perspective this is a
private institution this is a private
religious Institution
um
you know Yeshiva University just by its
very name you can't make any mistakes
about what it's about
and I'm sure that if you go to enroll in
a school like this
um all of these things are made very
clear
this is an Orthodox Jewish Institution
Al gets the only educational institution
in America or even in New York there are
many other options but if you come here
we are a religious Jewish institution we
abide by the by the Jewish religion and
that's it
so if we're being told by the left
and provisionally Anyway by the Supreme
Court
that private Jewish institutions don't
have the right to abide by the uh
religion by their religious faith in
their own institutions then in what
sense do we even have
religious rights anymore
this was all I always talk about the
leftist slight of hand trick here was
another one and it's always the same
thing
because for so many years they said as
they were driving religious people out
of the Public Square completely and and
uh driving them out and saying you know
your religion is not welcome here it's
not allowed here get it away get it get
it get it out of sight but then what
they always say they said well you know
do that in your own churches in your
your own schools okay if you want to be
in your home in your own private
religious schools your own churches uh
or synagogues as the case may be you
know you can have your religious freedom
there just just don't make us look at it
gross we don't want to see it
and many on the right as always went
along with that
I guess found that convincing
but it was always a lie
it always was
because you let them drive you out of
the Public Square relegate you to these
um
you know to their own little assign they
draw a circle
you know on the sidewalk and say like
they literally do on some college
campuses they say here's your free
speech Zone here's a religious freedom
Zone it's right here you can you can
have religious freedom in there
and then people go and they go stand in
a little circle and they say okay fine
I'll stand here and then what do they
find that circle gets smaller and
smaller and smaller until it disappears
this is a straightforward case
you know if you don't agree
with orthodox
um
Jewish people on the issue of of
homosexuality and gay marriage and gay
rights and all the rest of it if you
don't agree then don't go to an Orthodox
Jewish school
go anywhere else
so I also told you this is this is
what's going to happen with the
federalization the codification of of
gay rights on the federal level which
many Republicans are now supporting
that they're going to use that to go
after the churches too just like we
talked about yesterday
because once they establish once they
have codified into law this notion that
um gay marriage or quote gay rights are
you know it's a it's a human right issue
and um and and they've also defined gay
rights as just like if you're a gay
person you have the right to organize
and you have the right to uh you know um
behave in any way you want anywhere in
any context because that's what they
mean when they talk about gay rights
so once they've codified that then it's
a pretty it's a pretty simple maneuver
for them to go to the churches and say
well no you can't do this you could
still have your religious freedom you
can't infringe on human rights for
goodness sake
right next Jill Biden has some thoughts
on what books should be allowed or what
books should be available in libraries
let's listen to that
meanwhile there are schools all across
the country facing these shortages it's
such a challenge what concerned you the
most when we talk about Staffing for
schools this has been happening uh for a
couple years now we've seen it coming
the teacher Workforce was skewed a
little bit older you know for several
years now but what we need to do is
encourage younger people to to come into
the profession and and also teachers of
colors parents and politicians are now
weighing in on what books should be in
our school libraries and what their kids
are being taught where is the line in
your opinion with how much of a say
parents should have when it comes to
what their kids are learning in school
well I think with the pandemic parents
saw how hard teachers work and how
difficult this job really is and I think
if they work together in their school
districts and decide what they want with
their curriculum is there a balance
between you know this book should be in
the library this book should be in the
library all books this is America we
don't ban books
okay so at the very end that we get to
the part that that I wanted the rest of
it who cares about uh because it shows
the absurdity of the leftist claim
that you know books are being banned by
conservatives there's some sort of
Crisis this book burning that goes on
and of course as we know the actual book
burning and you know um uh the Banning
of of books and the Banning of ideas
de-platforming almost almost all of that
is the leftist thing
and and they also are the only ones with
the power to do it because they they
control the institutions which can then
pass these rules down
but you see the absurdity she says that
all books should be available in
libraries and here we are specifically
talking we're not talking about the
public library down the street we are
specifically talking about libraries at
schools and so she is saying all books
should be available to kids
in a in a school library
they're sitting in a school library
there it looks like an elementary school
library they're sitting in
every single book should be available to
to kids in an elementary school library
I mean forgetting about the logistic
challenge of putting every single book
in existence in a school library also so
you're suggesting that there are no
books that are inappropriate for kids
they're not even debating whether this
or that particular book is inappropriate
they're saying well every book is
appropriate of course there's no such
thing as inappropriate material for a
child
but don't call them groomers of course
never do that
all right Nancy Pelosi has some rather
glib thoughts on the issue of when life
begins let's listen
there is a conflict within the
Republican party there are those in the
party that think life begins at the
candlelight dinner the night before
and and and and these people are in
defiance of that right they're in
defiance of that because they're saying
whatever they're saying about it so
that's that's what you're seeing there
but we are united in our support for
women's right to choose
okay so Nancy Pelosi again like like
every other Democrat and we went through
a bunch of Clips yesterday uh she is
taking the gift that was given to her by
Lindsey Graham who I am convinced is
intentionally trying to sabotage
Republican chances in the midterms you
know who put forward this abortion ban
this Federal abortion ban right before
the midterms uh we already went over why
that was by political that is only a
political move it's it's not anything
else because the bill obviously has no
chance of being signed into law or
passing or even getting a vote so it's a
political play and we talked about why
that's a disastrously stupid political
play although we should also note that
the the bill itself even though
politically it makes no sense right now
the bill itself is quite moderate
it's not extreme at all
I mean they're going around with their
acting like their hair's on fire
screaming it's extreme it's extreme
what the bit when's the grounds Bill
does is it bans abortion after 15 weeks
which has many on the right have pointed
out as Lindsey Graham pointed out
accurately so this just puts the United
States right in line with most European
countries most civilized countries
across the world
um 15 weeks
you know my my wife is a little bit more
than 15 weeks but she's right around
there
I mean 15 weeks is late
it is late into a pregnancy
and at 15 weeks now you don't have uh
unborn babies who are viable in the
sense of we say viable meaning you can
take them out of the womb and they can
survive completely on their own
but they are developed like recognizable
human beings you look at the ultrasound
of 15 weeks and you will see little
babies there
so it's a moderate
bill
but Democrats are taking the gift that
they've been given and um
painting it like this extreme attack on
quote unquote women's rights
but you notice her little quip there
well you know Republicans they they
think life begins at the candlelight
dinner the night before
now obviously that's not even close to
True she's she's trying to make it sound
like conservatives are
confused like she's trying to confuse
the issue about what when conservatives
say when pro-life or say life begins
we're very clear about it life begins at
the moment that this living being comes
into existence that's it
Life Begins so another way we could put
it we always say life begins at
conception
maybe a simpler more direct uh
clarifying way of putting it is that
life begins at existence
that's what we should be saying from now
on
not life begins at conception
even though that is accurate better way
of putting it is life begins at
existence
and when you put it that way you you are
now putting the pro abortion people in
the position of trying to argue
that life begins sometime after
existence
that somehow you know
human life and human existence are these
two separable things
and first and first a human being comes
into existence and then at some other
point in the future they have life and
then those two things come together
that makes no sense
but because they're confused and are
constantly obfuscating on this issue and
trying to make it obscure and impossible
to understand
you know there there are strategy is to
make it seem like we're in the same boat
like we're all just confused fumbling
around in the dark who knows
no we have a firm solid understandable
answer to this you do not
which means by the way
um
like if if you don't know when life
begins you can't tell us that we're
wrong
because by your own admission you don't
really know
so as far as you're concerned we could
be right
we can say that you're wrong because we
have a firm position we're saying Life
Begins here and so that puts us in a
position where we could say no according
to our view you're wrong
but if you don't know you can't say that
anyone else is wrong because you don't
know
all right Chris uh rufo has
an update that I wanted to read to you
he posted this on Twitter he says update
I spoke with Boston Police Department
about the bomb threat at Boston
Children's Hospital
a spokesman told me um quote the threat
itself did not get reported to police it
came second hand
but he refused to say who alerted Boston
Police Department telling me it was part
of the investigation file
Denver fo continues I've submitted a
public records request asking for a
transcript of the communication alerting
Boston Police Department about the bomb
threat The Washington Post jumped to
conclusions without substantiating the
facts the public has a right to know
what happened it's entirely possible the
official narrative is correct but we
need answers to a few questions who
alerted BPD about the bomb threat how
did they communicate this info and where
is the evidence to substantiate claims
of threats and harassment against Boston
Children's the burden of proof is on the
media
um
we know that other outlets such as axios
have made claims of harassment against a
children's hospital without reviewing or
providing any evidence journalists need
to have a higher standard than this and
um
and then he wraps it up and says again
it's entirely possible if the Washington
Post narrative is true but there are
claims that need to be substantiated
questions that need to be answered
Boston Children's Hospital and Boston
Police Department should provide the
evidence to the public so just the way
that they are and it hasn't just been
Chris Ruffo I've been in communication
with other
um
people on the right in media that have
been doing this to have been trying to
track down answers about this bomb
threat
it was the biggest story everyone was
talking about for about five minutes a
couple weeks ago and people like myself
and Chris rufo himself and lived at Tick
Tock and others had been you know
accused
of
maybe calling in the bomb threat
ourselves or at least of encouraging
others to do it even though none of us
ever encouraged anything like that
and then the story goes away
and we the ones who are being accused
here are the only ones still interested
in talking about it
I mean I'm the one saying to the
left-wing media why'd you stop talking
let's let's still talk about the bomb
threat the Boston Children's Hospital I
want I actually want to know what
happened
who did it I want to know that you do
you apparently you don't want to know
which really tells us something
but this is what we've seen I've seen
this from multiple sources that any
attempt to reach out to Boston Police
Department and just find out what
happened
is they they are very strangely vague
about it
even the wording here so he's giving
this is what the spokesman told him
verbatim the threat itself did not get
reported to police it came second hand
what does that mean
the threat didn't get reported I mean
are they saying that the threat was not
it's like whoever made the threat didn't
call 9-1-1 but made the threat to Boston
Children's and then they heard about it
through that
is that what they're saying because
that's one thing
but what they're saying is that the
threat itself did not get reported to
police so they just heard about it
second hand
how do you make sense I don't even I
don't know what that means
and again rufo and others have tried to
clarify what does this mean exactly what
are you saying like where did this
threat come from are you still
investigating it how did this come in
how was the threat made
what was the threat exactly what what
was said on this call or whatever
however the threat came in what what was
contained in the threat exactly
they won't answer any of those questions
and uh
we can't know exactly why we can only
speculate
but here's the thing when when
information is being kept from us
and we're being given intentionally
vague answers
then it's not our fault that we have to
speculate that's not on us
so I feel perfectly free offering
speculations
I'd like to have something better than
speculation but they won't tell us
and so my speculation
my theory of the case
is that
um
this was not a conservative or a Critic
of gender ideology who called it a
threat to Boston Children's
that wouldn't even make any sense I mean
someone who is actually a Critic of what
Boston Children's is doing a Critic of
gender ideology you gain nothing there
is no motivation there is no incentive
to call it a bomb threat no incentive
even aside from the fact that it's
obviously a morally wrong atrocious
thing to do
um but if you're the kind of person that
you don't care about that so the
morality of it doesn't mean anything to
you
or from a from a basic strategic
perspective also it makes no sense
who does it benefit you know anytime you
hear about something happening
and it's very vague and speculative we
don't know exactly what happened
the first question you should ask
yourself is who benefits from this
does the right benefit from a bomb
threat to Boston children do I benefit
those Libs of tick tock benefit
obviously not
the the left reaps all the benefits here
because they can use this to de-platform
or try to de-platform people like myself
which is exactly what they did and have
been doing
so I don't know I mean that's what
we have some dots there can we connect
them
doesn't benefit anybody on the right
benefits on the left
we know that on the left they have a
habit of using hoaxes to get what they
want
this is a well-established thing they do
it all the time it just happened down at
BYU
very very frequent
so we have people with a habit of using
hoaxes for ideological and political
reasons self-serving reasons and it also
just happens that these are the only
people who benefit from this thing
and we're not being given any
information about it I don't know
seems like uh
although they're trying to make the
picture very unclear it seems to be
getting clear and clear by the day let's
get to the comment section
required that you grow a beard hey we're
the sweet baby gang
Walsh says no relation I think anyway I
remember being in public school in the
early mid 2000s and sex ed was taught by
our PE coaches we had one teacher who
tried to actually teach abstinence
during the course and I distinctly
remember the vast majority of my
classmates thinking he was weird and
creepy because it was so different than
literally everything else taught by all
the other teachers
um I got to recall this too I don't know
if this is still the case but they had
the gym teachers teaching sex ed which
is already strange but it's strange for
anyone to do it and but here's the thing
Jack I I agree
with the classmates who think that it's
weird and creepy to have some teacher up
there whether it's a gym teacher or the
health teacher or anybody else teaching
them about abstinence
I think that's weird and creepy too
now it's a lot weirder and creepier to
be teaching the kind of uh sex ed that
we talked about yesterday on the show to
be teaching the kind of sex ed that the
left wants that's a hell of a lot
creeper creepier and weirder
but it is also weird and creepy to be
talking about absence of public school
because
this is just a subject that should not
be discussed at all
now I don't want Public School teachers
teaching kids about how to use
pornography teaching about masturbation
and all these things that you hear about
in these Pub in these uh sex ed classes
I don't want that that's disgusting and
horrible and it should be criminal and
and people that do that should go to
prison
but I also don't want them to have to be
tasked with teaching kids how to refrain
from sex
but it's also not a conversation that I
want to
enlist the government education system
in
it's just just it should not be talked
about
how to have sex how to not have sex
shouldn't be talked about
strange adults should not be talking to
kids about that period stick with you
know the ABCs and one two threes
um
Philip says I asked my five-year-old
daughter what is a woman immediately and
without hesitation she responded a
grown-up girl like Mommy looked at me
confused and walked away she gets it
well that's that's good she obviously
understands reality better than most
adult people on the left and now your
job is just to make sure that uh she you
know retains that
recognition of reality as she grows
older
um
Delta
says porn is a natural Human Experience
uh no it may be a common or nearly
Universal contemporary experience but
that doesn't mean it's natural or good
yeah we heard that from The Advocates of
porn literacy yesterday uh people that
are promoting the porn literacy classes
in Idaho public schools and one of the
reasons that they think they need to
teach porn literacy is that porn is
natural
and I I noted that also I didn't focus
on that I mean there's so many things to
tear apart when you hear this so I
didn't focus in on that part of it but
you're absolutely right that that
statement makes no sense porn is natural
I mean what does that even mean natural
what do you mean in this context
it's natural in the sense that natural
beings like physical beings are doing it
so if that's what you mean
but beyond that no I'm not sure how we
could call PornHub
a natural phenomenon
it didn't like arise it didn't it didn't
grow out of the ground like a tree
it is in many ways the one of the least
natural things you can possibly imagine
um Ken says I'm totally on board with
the bicycling thing I have to drive on a
road exactly like you described on my
way home from work and there's always
tons of people biking on these extremely
dangerous roads right at the time that
people are trying to get home from work
it's inconsiderate and rude not to
mention dangerous there are plenty of
bike paths and other designated biking
areas that they could be using
yeah they do seem to to especially
choose
um
the worst roads to bike on and the and
the worst times
so they you know if you're in the the
cyclist Community you could at least
make it a little bit easier on everybody
by choosing times like middle of the day
when it's not during a commute and at
least choose roads that um people can
pass you without without having to drive
an oncoming traffic and get into a
head-on collision can you at least do
that
but no that's that's too much to ask
because these people are
selfish sociopaths
and should also be in prison that's my
solution to everything just put everyone
in prison
you know this week Obama Economist
Lawrence Summers said that we have a
serious problem with inflation which is
a direct quote but Joe Biden has refused
to see it that way calling the economy
fast and strong
if only we had his eyes uh in his brain
well I don't want his brain but his eyes
anyway well we thought we'd give the old
man the benefit of the doubt and applied
his fiscal policies to our daily wire
merch sale to see if it gave you a
better deal after crunching the numbers
we quickly realized no one wants to pay
8.3 percent more for anything so instead
we're going with our gut and we're going
to do what makes sense to us we're
cutting prices by 40 that's right you
can now get a copy of my best-selling
children's book Johnny The Walrus for
only twelve dollars and get a sweet baby
gang t-shirt for 21. you get an Old
Glory baseball bat signed by Ben Shapiro
for just a hundred and fifty dollars
this is this is this is the time you
know if you haven't gotten your sweet
baby gang t-shirt because you're being
cheap and saying I don't want to spend
all that well we are inviting you into
the fold now even the cheap people can
be in the sweet baby gang get your
T-shirt now uh you get 40 off daily wire
merchandise during our inflation
reduction event while supplies last just
go to dailywire.com shop sale ends on
Sunday now let's get to our daily
cancellation foreign
by the way I am looking forward to the
Media Matters headline daily wire host
calls for imprisoning all cyclists which
yet again I mean go ahead and make a
headline out of that because I'm 100
serious I really want to do that and I
would if I was in charge now
um for ideally cancellation I cannot say
that it's a major Shock by any means but
in recent weeks I have learned that the
Starbucks Baristas Community includes
some of the whiniest most self-pitying
humans who have ever existed on the face
of the planet and this doesn't apply to
all of them there are exceptions of
course but the whiners are a large
enough contingent so that every week it
would seem there's another viral post on
Twitter from a barista complaining about
customers about working conditions about
the lack of pay the lack of tips Etc but
the one thing that this group hates the
most it seems is when they're asked to
do the job they signed up for so earlier
this week on Twitter it was posted a
thread with instructions someone posted
a thread with instructions on how to
order various fancy Frappuccino drinks
and lattes
these are not on the drive-through menu
but they're drinks that Starbucks can
make if you ask and uh they're kind of
complicated now I'm I'm personally not
one to order fancy drinks and I can't
say that I particularly enjoy being
stuck in line behind a fancy drink
Enthusiast but this is why the Baristas
are there it's why they have jobs if
everybody was like me and simply wanted
a humble medium roast coffee about 80 of
Starbucks staff would just become
immediately useless we wouldn't need
them
and yet many members of the Starbucks
team responded to the Tweet complaining
bitterly about the very customers who
saved them from redundancy so I'll read
a few of these responses which are
representative of many others quote hey
just so you know Baristas despise these
hyper customized drinks it throws us off
our Rhythm Starbucks understaffeds us
and expects us to make a drink every 48
seconds drinks that aren't routine take
longer and put us behind in a stressful
environment try ordering a latte another
one says imagine pumping out 120 plus
drinks an hour and having to clear the
drive through in less than 46 seconds
this isn't cute it's labor abuse
yes that's right it is abusive for a
customer to ask a customer service
worker to provide them with service
another comment says each of these
drinks is going to cost at least nine
dollars because of all the additions
also your Baristas will hate you
and indeed many other Baristas confirm
this some threatening physical violence
against any customer who dares to make
them get off their asses and do the job
they're paid to do but Twitter's not the
only forum for these uh bitching
Baristas Tick Tock has become so far as
I can tell also um a forum really really
a forum primarily
for dancing and also for Barista
complaints and sometimes for Barista
complaints in the form of dancing
so the Daily Dot reports on one recent
example quote a barista is going viral
on Tick Tock after uploading a routine
customer experience he has while making
drinks that have cold foam in them
Marquis maynell said in a caption for
the popular clip which garnered 100 000
likes on the social media platform that
it happens daily several other Baristas
in the comment section said that they've
experienced the same type of anxious
requests from patrons that they've
served as well the video video begins
with Marquis setting down a cup of cold
brew it's an iced coffee with a text
overlay that reads okay and here's the
cold brew let me add your cold foam the
Barista then starts adding the foam to
the cup before another text overlay
meant to represent an interjecting
customer comes up on the screen don't
forget my cold phone it reads Marquis
adds the foam to the drink which he was
in the middle of doing in the video
before the customer reminded him not to
pour it in their cup he then gives the
customer a glare before walking off
camera now by the way
he was actually at Starbucks apparently
uh on the clock when he made this video
complaining about the customers at
Starbucks
so this is another very common thing
like these Starbucks employees are
making videos complaining about their
job while on the job so the next time
you're sitting in line at Starbucks
wondering what's taking so long keep in
mind that they they you you might be
getting held up because the employees
haven't finished uploading their tick
tocks yet another Tick Tock video has
this caption on the screen quote just
reminding everyone that Starbucks
Baristas can see you in the
drive-through when you're at the box so
I saw you make faces and throw your
hands up and say stuff under your breath
your friend because I asked you what
size pink Drink you wanted I'm sorry I
didn't hear you the first time uh I
didn't mean to offend you another
Barista agreed with this warning
customers that if she doesn't like your
attitude at the drive-through line she
will intentionally make your order wrong
still there's another recent Tick Tock
video featuring a barista complaining
about people who order Frappuccinos too
early in the morning
I've also heard complaints about people
who order complicated drinks too close
to closing time so
don't order them in the morning don't
order them at night
don't order them in the afternoon
because that's when all the workers are
making Tick Tock videos that just don't
order the drinks at all
don't go to Starbucks because your
presence is an in position on the
employees but also
the employees all need higher wages
so this is what they demand Less
business less work higher wages
economics 101 folks
now here's the point that needs to be
made
and it's not just Baristas who need to
hear this yes they seem to be an
especially aggrieved Bunch constantly
persecuted by customers who
you know order things but this is a
symptom of a widespread cultural
epidemic we hear constant complaints
from all sectors of the Working World
among high and low paid workers even
Hollywood actresses worth millions like
Jennifer Lawrence will still
relentlessly complain about their jobs
now if there's legitimate abuse going on
actual Injustice
then those should be exposed and
addressed but someone making a
complicated order or getting a little
annoyed with you is not abuse and it's
not an injustice
it's just the job it's the job you
signed up for it's the reason your
position exists
so here are some things that anyone
should think about before they start
whining and moaning about their job and
this this no matter what your job is
this goes for Starbucks Baristas people
in my line of work whatever it is
number one
your job is not as difficult or taxing
as you think it is
has its challenges
but there are many jobs more difficult
than yours
every job has its own sources of
frustration this is the other thing you
hear from Barista is anytime you talk
about this and they're complaining and
you say you should comply so you tried
doing this sometime you can't imagine
how hard this is you could never do this
but try working a customer service job I
mean I've done that lots of us have I'm
not saying it it has its difficulties it
is kind of stressful but it's not it's
it's something that a lot of us have
done and can do
your job is not as difficult as you
think
two um also remember that you pursued
this job you asked for it
you went to the employer and said can I
have this job please I want to do this
and then they said yes you can do it
here are your job the responsibilities
and you said yes I'll do those
responsibilities
like there are people who don't have a
job and would love to take yours if it's
such a burden also keep that in mind
three you don't deserve any special
Commendation simply for showing up you
have to work and even when you work you
still don't deserve special Commendation
just for that it's what's expected it's
your responsibility it's your duty you
aren't a martyr simply for filling your
basic responsibilities
four successful people
are always the ones who go to their jobs
looking to add extra challenges to their
day
that might sound like it might might
throw you for a loop it might sound
crazy but people who are really
successful they that's what they do no
matter what their line of work is they
go into their job and they're looking
actually to make the job harder they're
looking for more challenges more things
to do
they want to challenge themselves at the
job
and if that sounds if that sounds
mind-boggling to you can't even imagine
someone doing that
well it's why you are not as successful
as you could be
if you sit around all day you know
dwelling on the difficulties of your
work and trying to avoid them you will
languish in mediocrity forever you will
never be successful you will never
amount to anything worthwhile
and five most importantly and here I
climb atop uh a familiar soapbox once
again
but I have to just say it the the my
classic dad speech
life is work there is no such thing as a
work-free life every life requires work
to sustain it either you will do that
work for yourself or someone else will
be made to do it for you now the latter
option may seem attractive but there's
no honor in it and there's no success in
it there's no happiness and it's
certainly not the ethical approach it's
also not an option for most people
no in your case most likely just like in
my case we have to work we have no
choice that that's it that's life it
just is
it's the nature of human existence
so you might as well put some effort in
and have a good attitude about it and
strive for Success you have you have to
do this so you can sit around
complaining all day it's too hard I want
to do it it's so difficult but it
doesn't matter you're alive you're a
human this is just what life is
so you might as well accept it
and try to make the most of it
and one more guideline if you're going
to complain about your job if you are
going to complain about it and I'm not
we all complain about our job sometimes
but if you are going to do it
do it in the break room in Whispers like
a normal person don't do it on the
internet
these Starbucks Baristas have have
violated all of these rules in
particular though they violate that last
one and so that is why finally they are
the ones who are today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there sign up for
a daily wire membership if you haven't
yet so you can join us for the final
portion of the show if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]